psychologiquement c'est quand même assez
dur un joueur frontières six jours après
l'attaqué les à mahmoud rentre enfin
chez elle la femme de 24 ans vient de
subir une troisième opération
chirurgicale cette fois pour soigner sa
main gauche l'épaule droite et mon avant
bras c'était directement le dimanche
matin je me tairai en urgence samedi
soir dernier un peu avant 22h30 elle
marche avec son ami pierre lag revol sur
la rue de buade dans le vieux québec
soudainement un homme armé d'un sabre
surgit juste devant eux
il arrivait vraiment de comme presse de
nulle part
puis il a commencé à attaquer pierre
quoi la tête puis quoi l'épaule pierre
est tombé j'ai essayé de le remettre sur
au dossier de nous défendre
puis ça a été à mon tour je tombe au sol
je crois qu'il m'a peu brillant indien
six premiers coups de couteau le seul
souci c'est de me défendre
coup de pied ce qu'yves lisa est
convaincu qu'elle va mourir mais son ami
pierre interviennent tient à crier de
toutes ses forces
évidemment entendu un cri cri comme ça
honnêtement il c'est comme retourner
face à pierre pour pour aller sur pierre
à nouveau pierre a esquivé puis je me
suis levé je me suis mise à courir
pierre m'a attrapée on m'a tiré de
toutes ses forces mais parti en courant
les deux amis prennent la fuite vers
l'escalier frontenac leur agresseur est
tout près il s'est mis à l'eau tous
commencé à courir puis il y en a comme
croiser quelqu'un chemin donc nous on
était un criée ont crié puis je pense
que c'est ça qu'il affiche qui l'a fait
fuir la résidante de québec d'origine
française tenait à raconter son histoire
à tout le monde qu'il fût inhumain de
faire ça c'est inhumain donc moi je me
contente que ça a été vraiment une nuit
d'horreur d'un polype malheureusement
les deux personnes qui sont décédées et
puis bah mon ami pierre et les autres
crimes aussi pour lisa il faut dénoncer
la violence renoncer à la peur et
s'accrocher à la vie ici pascal point la
radio canada à québec